alors on veut plus rien dire on va faire
le test ultime pour savoir si on peut
vraiment plus rien dire on va faire une
interview fin de phrase je dis pas qu'il
ya des [ __ ] des drogués à la télé jeudi
que magic ya deux ans il ya des gens il
ya des gens différents
pascal sevran il s'en est sorti par
exemple nouveaux corps ce qui est bien
quand et pdc
bah c'est que t'as pas besoin de divorce
est encore fécond savent tenir là je
rêve d'une france nettoyer deux des
journalistes qui me posent des questions
de combat mais vraiment c'est celle et
déjà invités du dîner
nicolas sarkozy a raison il faut
absolument faire parler de soi
il ne faut pas jeter la pierre au
pédophile car tu pourrais me laisser
l'enfant qui porte dans les bras tu vois
thierry un handicapé s'est toujours fait
un mec qu'a pas de chance il ya plein de
place pour les handicapés de
stationnement on interdit la voiture en
ville
je suis pour la parité hommes femmes
bien sûr sauf si sauf si laurent baffie
remplacé par christine boutin
la phrase qu'il ne faut surtout pas dire
en ce moment c'est on peut pas plaire à
tout le monde
j'aime bien voir des flics dans la rue
parce que ils sont pendants le bistrot
le vrai problème avec les juifs
aujourd'hui c'est pour problème on dit
que les arabes sont voleurs c'est faux
il ya des problèmes tous les musulmans
ne sont pas des terroristes mais hormis
les petites musulmane c'est des petites
bombes à la qualifier on pourra jamais
enlever un islamiste c'est d'emmerdés
bush
ça sera bien
ce qui m'énerve chez les catholiques
c'est ça c'est qu'ils élisent des papes
un peu trop un peu trop black et surtout
trop jeune les inconnues sont mais qu'on
met tout le monde en parle voilà
exactement je veux être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus